What I'd like to do now is look into this issue in a little bit more detail.
If we think about a piece of software as a mathematical object--
and of course that's very natural for something like a square root function,
but we can do this for any piece of software--
if we think of a piece of software as a mathematical object,
what we'll find is the software has a domain of values.
The domain of values is just a set of possible values
that constitutes the set of inputs that the software is designed to handle.
Correspondingly, every piece of software also has a range.
This is the set of possible outputs for the software.
And so let's look at what the domain and range are for the square root function.
Earlier we said that we probably would like to return the positive answer for a square root,
and we also said that we were probably not going to be able to compute
the square root of a negative number.
We can account for both of those facts in the square root's domain and range
by making it a function from non-negative real-valued numbers
to non-negative real-valued numbers.
Alternatively, if we're implementing some sort of mathematical software,
we might want to define square root for all real-valued numbers,
in which case the domain is the full set of real numbers,
and then the range is the set of complex numbers.
Actual computer code is not going to be able to deal with a full set of real numbers.
Most real-valued numbers are not representable on a computer at all.
So instead of dealing with the reals, we're going to worry about floating-point numbers.
So for example, we might want to make square root
a function from non-negative floating-point numbers
to the set of non-negative floating-point numbers.
But this isn't really very convenient.
What should we do if somebody calls square root with a negative number?
What languages like Python often do is declare square root
over the full range of floating-point numbers
and give outputs that are the positive ranged floating-point numbers
unioned with a different behavior, which is to throw an exception.
And so this bottom domain and range for floating point
is the situation we actually get in many real programming languages.
So now given the specification, let's get back to software testing and ask the question,
should we test this square root function with negative inputs?
Now let's bring the discussion back to testing and take a little quiz.
The question is, given this specification here
where square root maps the full set of floating-point numbers
onto either a floating-point number or a math exception,
should we test this code with negative inputs?
And the answers are either yes, we should test it with negative inputs,
or no, we should not. So take a minute now to mark down your answer.